NOW OBVIOUSLY TONIGHT I NEED TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING FOR THE
RECORD.
NOW LAST SATURDAY A WHITE COP IN
SOUTH CAROLINA KILLED A BLACK
MAN NAMED WALTER SCOTT. OFFICER
MICHAEL SLAGER
STOPPED SCOTT FOR A BUSTED TAIL
LIGHT -- NOT A VIOLENT CRIME
AND SOMEHOW SCOTT WOUND UP DEAD.
THE POLICE IMMEDIATELY WENT ON
THE RECORD SAYING THAT SCOTT HAD
GAINED CONTROL OF THE OFFICER'S
TASER AND THAT'S WHY THE OFFICER
SHOT HIM. LATER SLAGER SAID
THROUGH HIS ATTORNEY THAT HE
FELT THREATENED AND FIRED
HIS WEAPON. AND SO,
FOR THE RECORD THIS CRAZY BLACK
THUG WAS ATTACKING HIM.
HE DID WHAT HE HAD TO DO. BUT
ALSO FOR THE RECORD,
THIS TIME WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
RECORD.
THERE IS A CELLPHONE VIDEO OF
THE SHOOTING OF SCOTT TRYING TO
RUN AWAY. THE COP SHOOTS HIM IN
THE BACK FIVE TIMES KILLING HIM.
NOW FOR THE ACTUAL RECORD, IT
APPEARS OFFICER SLAGER
IMMEDIATELY BEGAN THE COVER UP
OF WALTER SCOTT'S DEATH
HE HANDCUFFED SCOTT AS HE
LAID BLEEDING ON THE GROUND
AND PICKED UP THE WHAT LOOKS AN
AWFUL LOT LIKE THAT TASER
AND LAID IT NEXT TO SCOTT'S
BODY TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE SCOTT
WAS ARMED DURING THE
ALTERCATION. END OF STORY,
RIGHT? ANOTHER BLACK MAN SHOT
IN THE BACK BY A COP.
IT'S AS AN AMERICAN AS AN APPLE
PIE FILLED WITH BASEBALLS
COOKED BY A BALD EAGLE WITH THE
HEAD OF GUY FIERI
YESTERDAY AFTER THE VIDEO
EMERGED, OFFICER SLAGER WAS
CHARGED WITH MURDER. THAT'S THE
GREAT NEWS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: THANK YOU.
BY THE WAY, THAT'S HOW LOW THE
BAR IS RIGHT NOW ON GREAT NEWS.
RIGHT?
THE FACT THAT A COP WHO COLDLY
MURDERED SOMEONE ON CAMERA EVEN
FACES THE REMOTE POSSIBILITY OF
JUSTICE IS GIVING ME THE WARM
FUZZIES.
FOR THE RECORD ALL THIS GOOD
NEWS DOES IS MAKE ME THINK HOW
MANY MURDERS ARE NOT CAUGHT ON
CAMERA?
LET ME SHOW YOU A VIDEO OF
ANOTHER VIOLENT ALTERCATION
BETWEEN CITIZENS AND
POLICE..THIS COP IS GREAT.
RIGHT, HE HAS ONE GUY PINNED.
THEN ANOTHER GUY COMES UP.
YOU HAVE THESE DRUNK GUYS --
HE'S WRESTLING THEM.
WHEN DOES THE GUN COME OUT?
NOW HE'S DETAINING TWO CRAZY
BROS WHO ARE WILDING OUT.
THIS IS GOING TO TURN TRAGIC ANY
SECOND.
WAIT, THAT'S IT?
THESE TWO WHITE GUYS JUMPED A
POLICE OFFICER AND THEY'RE IN A
THREE-WAY SAND TICKLE FIGHT.
THE BROTHER IN SOUTH CAROLINA
WAS RUNNING FROM THE COP AND
HE'S NOT ALIVE TODAY.
I SAID IT ONCE BEFORE.
I WILL STOP TALKING ABOUT THIS
[BEEP] WHEN IT STOPS HAPPENING,
FOR THE RECORD.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.